it's a lot easier to actually write a  screenplay than you think it is might  not be good but most people  talk about writing screenplays but don't  actually write them the people who write  them you're already like in you know the  top 10 percent because you actually have  written it i remember when i was in  college  i spent most of my time in my room  writing screenplays um really bad  screenplays but i was in my room doing  that there were a lot of people i  remember at parties who would talk about  writing and that they wanted to be a  writer but i would always notice they  were out every time i would happen to go  out they would always be out  and they i just know that that there are  people who talk about what they would do  if  but they're not actually doing the thing